Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my bonus Arrow video I’m going to breakdown
the Justice League movie that they just announced
with Zack Snyder.
So we’ll start with all the confirmed stuff
first and then all the characters and stories
I think they should do.
I know a lot of you have been asking me about
how TV Shows like Arrow and Stephen Amell
are going to be involved so I’ll talk about
that too.
If you’re finding me for the first time
every week I’m doing a bonus Arrow video
counting down to episode 23 the finale.
That’s in two weeks.
There’s only two more episodes.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
and leave me suggestions for for those other
bonus vids.
So first thing, Warner Brothers confirmed
Zack Snyder will direct Justice League and
that it will shoot back to back with Superman
VS Batman.
So it’s possible if they get the script
done quickly enough, they could hit a 2017
release date.
But plan for spring 2018.
The haven’t announced who will be writing
it, but I would assume that several people
will be involved.
Christopher Nolan has kind of moved on from
DC Movies, he wasn’t really involved at
all with the Superman VS Batman script.
That was all David S. Goyer and Zack Snyder.
They’ll definitely be part of the writing
team for Justice League, but because casting
Ben Affleck was such a big deal.
I wouldn’t be surprised if he has script
approval and Warner Brothers lets him take
a pass at the story.
Christopher Nolan could always be helicoptered
in for any emergencies too.
Justice League is a huge risk for them, so
they’ll spare no expense in making sure
it makes billions of dollars.
Now let’s talk about cast, the holy trinity
will of course be back as will all the secondary
characters they’ve announced recently for
Superman VS Batman including Jesse Eisenberg
as Lex Luthor, Jeremy Irons as Alfred and
Ray Fisher as Cyborg.
But what about all the other Justice League
members that are already on TV, like Stephen
Amell and Grant Gustin?
Green Arrow and The Flash are core team members.
And I know a lot of you want them to be in
the movie.
Here’s the reality, because Zack Snyder
is doing Justice League, it implies that the
tone of the movie will be consistent with
his Man of Steel movies.
So the story will flow with the same energy
and visually the world will look the same.
There will just be more characters and a more
complex story.
Superman VS Batman started filming in February
and that will take about six months to finish.
So if Justice League will film back to back
it means this fall they’ll start shooting
it in the fall right in the middle of Arrow
Season 3 and The Flash Season 1.
Which is bad news for anyone that wants to
see Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin in the
movie.
That doesn’t me they won’t be in it.
It just means there’s zero chance they’ll
have major roles.
They could always have a two second cameo
just wearing plain clothes.
And they could always be name-dropped by the
other characters.
Warner Brothers won’t ever say “no they’re
not going to be in it.”
Never say never, but just looking at those
shooting schedules.
I’m pretty sure they’re not going to be
in it.
What about other characters though.
There’s tons of Justice League characters.
Here’s my Top 5 I think should get cameos:
Number 5 - Zatanna
They haven’t established magic in the Man
of Steel Universe, so they’d have to bend
some of the logic on her powers.
But they have to include some more girl power
on the team.
A lot of people got upset at JJ Abrams and
Disney when it seemed like the new Star Wars
trilogy would be a total boys club.
Number 4 - Aquaman
Again, they’d have to get a little timey
wimey with his backstory and powers.
How could Superman have those amazing senses
and not know about a race of highly advanced
Atlanteans living in the ocean.
But Aquaman could always cameo as a normal
person, not in costume.
Like Oliver Queen getting a cameo, not The
Arrow.
Number 3 - Shazam
Again, another magic user so they’d have
to establish a credible explanation for his
powers.
Or he could just be Billy Batson in the movie.
But right now Dwayne Johnson is developing
a project with DC and Warner Brothers and
it’s supposed to be Shazam.
Number 2 - Supergirl
Again, I think it would be fun for a Kara
cameo.
Not a full on suit-wearing Supergirl.
It’s just another interesting way of deepening
the new Man of Steel mythology they created
with the first movie.
and my number 1 new character - Martian Manhunter
We’ll need Oreos, lots and lots of Oreos.
Even if they don’t include him officially.
It would be so awesome if they added easter
eggs for him in the form of cookies.
In reality, they probably already have all
the characters they want and when you look
at Superman VS Batman on paper, it kind of
is a World’s Finest version of Justice League
anyway.
So just expect the story of that movie to
tie directly into the events of Justice League.
The rumors right now are that Batman is going
to hate the crap out of Superman for most
of the movie.
No idea on how Wonder Woman is going to enter
the story.
But the Justice League won’t form until
all the characters unite in common cause against
Lex Luthor and whatever other villains they
use.
So now it’s your turn.
Let me know which characters you’d like
to see in Justice League and what kind of
a story you’d like them to do.
My Arrow video tonight will post right after
the episode airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it and my regular
Q&A will post on Thursday.
Right now click here to get that review video,
I’ll update the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here for the q&a.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!